the first sounds at dawn and lizzy
shanks are always the same now
[Music]
the whistle of incoming fire from close
by russian positions
even in the shelters we've heard the
rumble of war above all night and it's
the first sound you hear on waking
we've agreed not to film anyone
sheltering with us but there are
families with young children here
the city has been bombed to bits
vitaly one of the police still here
cannot believe the level of destruction
three quarters of the city center has
gone i think that the infrastructure of
the chance will be destroyed as a
serotonin infrastructure
i think
similar
the twin cities sever donetsk is just
over this bridge now under russian
control lissy shanks is on the brink of
being next
aid center after aids center has been
shattered this seems a deliberate
attempt to starve the city into
submission
so this used to be a humanitarian hub
and you can see it
it's absolutely destroyed by fire
by all sorts
and they're coming under
continual
sustained attack
the russians are destroying everything
in their path
if and when they do
finally take over lisa shanks
they're going to inherit
a pile of rubble
it's mostly left to volunteers to
deliver aid
there are about 10 to 15 000 people
still in lissy shanks
many like svetlana don't want to leave
vitaly the volunteer has brought a few
essentials all desperately hard to get
hold of
now her husband fedia shows us the
bunker where they flee when the
shelling's too intense
federer doesn't buy into the western war
narrative he lives in a very pro-russian
area and is reluctant to say who is the
aggressor
there's a deep suspicion about ukrainian
soldiers here
where pro-russian separatists have made
their mark
much of the misery the daily even hourly
struggle to survive is blamed on them
even finding water is a mission
and listen to what they're singing
it's a soviet victory tune
at one of the city's lakes where they're
getting water few will talk to us this
group blames the ukrainian government
and all supporting them who do you blame
for the for the whole thing
the trees offer some visual cover but no
one feels safe here no one is safe and
every hour the city edges closer to
being cut off
so in this crazy urban battlefield
contact from far away family brings
tears and joy
her grandsons fighting to keep the
russians out
neighbors in the same city find
themselves on opposite sides of this
wall
here
but there's no sign of an end at all
these ukrainian special forces inside
the city center are part of the troops
stopping the russians from entering
each delay allows time for more
bolstering of defensive positions
elsewhere
but for every inch of territory the
russian troops are paying for it heavily
in lives and equipment
russian media is now showing images of
themselves inside the city's oil
refinery where we saw such savage
engagement not more than 48 hours
earlier
they're highlighting bloody ukrainian
uniforms and weapons this defense comes
with deadly sacrifices
the ukrainians are trying to keep their
enemy from entering the city center
but this enemy is smashing its way in
they're landing every few minutes and
this one's been quite close
and there are frantic last attempts to
persuade people to leave
[Music]
[Applause]
he doesn't seem convinced many fear
they'll never return
but some have no choice
hanadi's held out so long but with the
fighting almost on his doorstep he's
taking probably his last chance to leave
among those fleeing a young mother and
her teenage son
a few hours earlier they were scrambling
out of their burning home after it was
hit
her husband didn't make it
they have no idea where they're going or
where they'll stay
[Music]
[Music]
the routes out of the city are
constantly shelled and tracked by
russian spotter drones and their troops
are steadily closing in on this corridor
to block it off entirely alex crawford
sky news in lizzie shanks in the donbass
in eastern ukraine